- How'd you get out of it?
I didn't get out of it.
And it wasn't funny.
And it wasn't okay.
- Yeah!
[cheers and applause]
[in slow-motion]
Yeah!
[indistinct slow-motion chatter]
[dark electronic music]
[in slow-motion]
- [growls]
[audience gasps]
♪
[grunts]
- [screaming]
♪
[mud splashes]
[slow-motion yelling]
♪
[grunting and yelling continues]
[struggling vocally]
♪
- Ladies and gentlemen,
please help me welcome
to the stage a very funny man.
Mr. Al Jackson, everybody!
Let him hear it.
[cheers and applause]
- Every comic that
y'all are gonna see tonight
has made it to a point
in their career
where you can kind of pick
and choose gigs.
You do what you want.
You skip
what you don't want to do.
This was one of my first shows,
and what y'all need to know
about this gig
is I was early in my career.
I was broke.
This was roof money.
This was "so rain doesn't hit
your head" money.
I was gonna do this show.
I was gonna do the show.
So the gig was a college
in Florida.
They put me up
in this really nice hotel,
and there were two things
that kind of stood out
about the gig just to start.
First of all,
they wanted me to wear a suit,
which, again--fine.
I was gonna do the show.
Second thing, the gig was
at 8:00 in the morning,
which, yeah,
good time for stand-up.
You know what I'm saying?
You want some eggs
with those dick jokes?
So didn't matter.
I'm gonna do the show.
No matter what,
I'm doing the show.
So I'm sitting in my room.
I rented a suit
from Men's Wearhouse.
And I'm sitting in my room,
and it's, like, 7:40,
and I'm walking out,
'cause the gig was in the w--
it was in the downstairs,
the ballroom
where people get married.
So it was inside the hotel.
So I'm getting ready
to go to the gig,
and I'm reaching for my door
handle, and I'm like,
"Wait, let me just see
how much time they want me to do
on the show," because
sometimes you get to a gig,
and in college gigs,
they want you to do an hour.
Because college gigs
are so different.
They're all different.
They're not like comedy clubs.
College gigs,
sometimes you'll do, like,
the University of Colorado.
It's already sold out,
and you kill it,
and they carry you out
of that bitch like Rudy.
And the next day you do
the University of Nevada,
and the show's at noon
in the cafeteria,
and the mic
is on the fucking floor,
and somebody just says,
"Just pick the mic up
and start talking."
I'm like, "That's not
how comedy shows start.
That's--people are
getting fish sticks."
So just remember that
all college gigs are different.
So I was like,
let me just check
and see how much time
this college gig want me to do.
And I looked,
and they wanted me
to do an hour,
which is fine.
I can do an hour.
But they didn't want me
to do stand-up.
They wanted me to do
an hour speech
on note-taking
and organization.
I know.
It's, like, 7:40, and I'm,
like, this must be a mistake,
but let me just make sure,
'cause this was back--
I'll tell you
back when this was,
this is back--I had an old
Mac PowerBook,
one of those big, silver Macs.
And yeah,
so I just pulled up--
I'll said just in case
they want me
to do some shit on note-taking,
let me just pull up--
so I pulled up an outline,
'cause I used to be a teacher,
so I was like,
I could bullshit my way
through this if I have to.
So I pulled up,
like, just a basic outline,
so if I had to, like,
refer to a--
worst-case scenario,
they wanted me
to do this, I'm fine.
So get my MacBook,
go downstairs,
get to the bottom
of the elevator,
and the elevator doors
open up,
and the liaison from the college
goes, "Are you Jackson?"
I go, "Yeah."
And she goes, "You're late."
She swings open the double doors
to this ballroom.
There are 750 college students
in suits, pantsuits,
MacBooks, iPads,
ready to hear this Negro
give a speech on something
he's never heard of.
And I know y'all are, like,
trying to get ahead of me,
like y'all are smart people.
Like, y'all are like, "But, Al,
how'd you get out of it?
"What's the funny part?
Get to the joke.
What's the funny part?"
I didn't get out of it.
And it wasn't funny.
And it wasn't okay.
I walked up there.
Got my Men's Wearhouse suit on.
I have a giant Mac with me
for no reason.
And I went up,
and it was like--
I'm a comic,
so if you give me a mic,
at least I can move around
and kinda--
but it was like
one of them podiums
that's got, like,
that Burger King microphone.
So you can't even, like, move.
You're just, like,
behind a podium
like Napoleon Dynamite.
So I put my MacBook down,
and this is--
this is the part that, like,
I hope y'all feel me
when I say this.
I'm in this ballroom with all
these kids looking at me,
and people that have Macs
can feel this.
I opened up my Mac,
and the battery just died,
like--
as I opened it.
It was just, like, instant.
It was just that grey apple.
I was just like, "Oh, shit."
But I can't let my face say,
"Oh, shit,"
'cause I'm already gonna bomb.
With the help of the computer,
I was already done.
I--this just--
I was just like, "Fuck!"
So.
This is happening.
And, uh...
I know a lot of people are like,
"But then what happened?
Like, how'd you get out of it?"
I didn't get out of it.
I stayed up there.
And I ate my dick for an hour.
'Cause I was gonna do this show.
And my first manager told me,
"If you don't do your time,
that's how colleges
don't pay you."
He was like, "Stay up there
and do your time."
I was gonna do this show.
And I stayed up there
for an hour.
And I know, like,
this is a comedic setting,
but you have to remove yourself
and think about how long
60 minutes is
in real time.
In real time, like,
how long 60 minutes is.
You know how
like every third year
it's your turn to give
the Thanksgiving prayer,
and it's super fucking awkward.
And how long is that,
40 Mississippi?
Think about if you had
to give the Thanksgiving prayer
for an hour this year.
Only you didn't know
what a prayer was.
I stayed up there
and I bombed.
The college kids, they didn't
know what was going on.
It was--I felt worse for them
'cause it was like
I might as well
have just gone up there and put
on a French film backwards.
Like, they didn't know
what was happening.
I didn't know
And I'm just bombing.
I'm sweating.
And I don't sweat
at all onstage,
but when you're bombing,
like, sweat starts coming
from, like, your side
and, like, weird places.
And it was
this young black dude
that booked me,
and he is, like--
he's got his cell phone
on that red light,
and he's waving it, giving me
the throat slash, like--
"Get off the stage.
Get off the stage."
And I'm like, "Nope,
you're not gonna pay me."
And I stayed up there
for the whole--
the whole time.
I get offstage,
and I have walk back through
the crowd of college kids
that just are stunned
at this point.
Like, no one's talking,
and I go to get my check
from the black dude,
and he's so mad at me,
he throws my check
on the ground.
I needed the money.
I went to go pick it up,
and as I reach down to get it,
like, this big, 6'3",
like, 50-year-old white guy
brushed past me so hard--
like, if he had done it,
like, in a bar like this,
it would've started a fight--
like, I mean,
he almost knocked me over.
And he goes straight up
on the stage, angrily,
and starts giving a speech
on note-taking and organization.
Funny story, kids.
The college fucked up
and sent me his contract.
[audience ohhs]
I was supposed to do
15 minutes of jokes
to liven up his boring-ass
note-taking speech.
And instead,
I did his speech for him,
only with zero knowledge.
'Cause I was gonna
do that show.
Guys, I've been Al Jackson.
Thank y'all so much.
Thank y'all.